Nowadays, everyone knows about The Matrix.
But when it first debuted in 1999, filmgoers
weren't quite sure what they were in for.
The movie's blend of such a large existential
framework with slick kung fu action scenes
elevated the Wachowskis and had everyone second-guessing
whether they'd take the blue pill or the red
pill.
But with two relatively new filmmakers at
the helm, it's a bit of a surprise such an
ambitious concept ever made it to celluloid,
let alone spawned such a cultural phenomenon.
So, let's take a look back at how The Matrix
came to be such a central part of the sci-fi
film world in the first place.
Odd origins
It's safe to say that The Matrix never would
have come to be if not for one really crappy
film.
1995's Assassins was a lazy action vehicle
for Sylvester Stallone and Antonio Banderas,
directed by Richard Donner in full paycheck-cashing
mode.
But Assassins wasn't just a bad movie...it
was also the Wachowskis' second completed
script, which was ultimately sold to Warner
Bros. In the end, the script itself is what
earned the pair a deal with Warner Bros.
Taking the helm
The Wachowskis developed a relationship with
Assassins producer Joel Silver, to whom they
showed their script for The Matrix early on,
and he was immediately blown away.
Silver remembered, "The minute I started reading
the script for The Matrix, I wanted to see
it … but then the [Wachowskis] said, 'And
we want to direct it.'
That was going to be tough."
Instead of taking a gamble on a script that
was obviously going to take a beefy budget
to realize, Silver took a more cautious approach:
He greenlit Bound, a smaller piece about lesbian
lovers on the run from the mob, which the
Wachowskis would write and direct.
The film was then made on a tight $6 million
budget and was a hit with critics.
That was almost enough to convince Warner
Bros. to let the newly-minted directors proceed
with their passion project.
But there was just one problem: while everyone
seemed to agree that The Matrix was a great
script, nobody understood the Wachowskis'
vision in the least.
"There is no spoon?"
So, the siblings had to improvise ...
Storyboarding
Producers were so confused by the premise
of The Matrix that the Wachowskis turned to
a pair of illustrators named Steve Skroce
and Geof Darrow to present the premise in
a format others might understand.
Skroce handled the storyboards, illustrating
scenes in a dramatic, noir-like style with
a heightened sense of motion and impact.
Meanwhile, Darrow handled concept art.
Now, for the first time, executives were able
to visualize how this crazy script would translate
to the screen.
It was enough for Warner Bros. to greenlight
a $60 million budget for The Matrix.
And the pre-production artwork was so impressive
that it was collected in a hardcover volume
the year after the film's release.
Casting calls
After executives hopped on board with the
Wachowskis' vision, they still wanted to maintain
some creative control over the project.
The cast, in particular, was to be decided
by Warner Bros., even though the Wachowskis
had some opinions of their own on the matter.
Keanu Reeves was not the Wachowskis' first
choice for the role of Neo.
Instead, they had their eyes on Johnny Depp.
Meanwhile, the studio wanted someone like
Brad Pitt, Val Kilmer, or Will Smith, all
of whom turned down the role.
"This is your last chance.
After this there is no turning back."
Neo's casting was eventually whittled down
to a choice between Depp and Reeves, the latter
of whom Warner Bros. preferred.
Eventually, the studio won out with the casting
of Reeves, and at least one star who turned
it down has no regrets.
Will Smith has said that he's glad he turned
down the role, as Reeves ended up being "brilliant."
Fight preparation
The Wachowskis envisioned the fight scenes
in The Matrix being heavy on fast-paced, close-quarters
martial arts combat with elements of wire
work.
So, they decided to appeal directly to the
world's foremost authority in martial arts
choreography, Yuen Woo-ping, director of such
classics as Drunken Master and the man who
made Jackie Chan a star.
Yuen wasn't interested — until he read the
script.
Unlike Warner Bros. executives, it took Yuen
almost no time to understand what they were
doing, and he agreed to bring his crew of
trainers to the production, where his work
began months before cameras ever started rolling.
All of the movie's stars were expected to
perform their own stunts, but most weren't
exactly known for being on-screen fighters.
So they had to spend months training with
Yuen's kung fu crew and wire workers and and
suffered a few injuries along the way.
And while it was a brutal preparation process,
the ends definitely justified the means for
these Matrix stars.
Satisfying the suits
It's an often-quoted piece of trivia that
Warner Bros. initially budgeted the film at
$10 million — only to have which the Wachowskis
use it to create a smash opening sequence,
and convince the studio to fund the full $60
million they needed.
But that's not exactly how it happened.
According to special effects supervisor John
Gaeta, the Australia-based production had
been scheduled for a 90-day shoot, and it
became obvious at a certain point that it
was falling significantly behind.
Executives were growing frustrated, so they
hatched a plan to clean up the opening sequence
and its visual effects, and add in some temporary
sound effects.
Once that was done, they sent it to the studio
to let them know just how production was coming
along.
After that, Warner Bros. immediately backed
off and gave them an additional month to complete
the film.
It was just enough time to make all that movie
magic happen, including the invention of a
new photography technique to capture those
slow-mo bullet shots.
Gaeta was inspired by the Japanese film Akira
and music video director Michel Gondry to
improvise his camera techniques to create
those memorable scenes.
He used over 100 still cameras and two motion
cameras to create the effect of a shot moving
into extreme slow motion, while the camera
appears to pan around or track the events
at a normal speed.
Each sequence that employed the technique
was first digitally simulated, then meticulously
staged with the camera array programmed to
shoot in a specific sequence with precise
timing.
This technique became known as "bullet time"
camera work and is a registered trademark
of Warner Bros.
So, not only did they get a full-on franchise
out of the deal, but they also made movie
history with The Matrix.
"Whoa."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!